meetup site so i hope everybody's a way
of
is okay with that um so very quickly
what's
pi data and what is this meetup about
so um we are part of the the outreach
program
of num focus which is a us-based
non-profit that promotes
open source software and um open science
and as part of the outreach program we
organize regular meetups and and have
also organized conferences in the past
and we are generally about you know
promoting
open source software promoting uh open
and scientific use of data
and you know promoting these practices
and spreading the news
about these tools we are four people
that are
organizing the meetup as volunteers
federico
who will uh join us later euris who is
also on the call
leando and myself ole and we are all
doing this as volunteers
so as a side activity
and a quick wrote about num focus
so num focus is uh
umbrella organization and and financial
sponsor
for many open source software packages
um if you look at the list here you will
you you're very likely to see a name
that that
rings a name and that you have used
in the past so you know very well known
packages like numpy
uh from the python world around theirs
and
uh senpai and jupiter and pandas all the
big names
but also non-python languages such as
julia so they're really doing an awful
lot in terms of
promoting these projects supporting them
financially with
scholarships so if you in turn want to
support these projects as well then
please do
consider a donation to nam focus
there's a link at the bottom and i'm
going to say a bit more about the
various ways that you can support them
as well
um another quick thing code of conduct
um it's should be really just
common sense um we
cannot tolerate any uh insults or put
down
the general theme here is you know be
kind to each other and behave proof
professional any sort of harassment or
sexist racist exclusionary behavior
is not appropriate for high data and we
cannot accept
if you feel that something hasn't gone
quite
right at the meet up and you feel that
there has been a violation of the code
of conduct
you can contact the code of conduct
response team that's all the organizers
i'm going to put our emails out at the
very end but we have also like an
external contact person if you're
feeling more comfortable
to speaking to someone who is uh not
part of the meetup
um and her name is leonie her email is
mentioned here at the end and you can of
course go to num focus through
directly if you if you feel like it um
a few community updates we
are looking for speakers to present in
2021
next year basically so if if you're
interested
um please step forward and contact us
you know email us contact us on
meetup.com tweet to us you
you know do do whatever is is most
easiest for you but yet now do step
forward
i can only only say um it doesn't have
to be a sophisticated it doesn't have to
be a very long talk we can
really accommodate all sorts of um
formats and and and ways of presenting
it can even be something as short as
like a quick
presentation of your favorite open
source tool
or or some data analysis that you did
recently so
you know don't be shy um and and you can
of course you're welcome just to
email us with some very rough ideas and
and we are happy to sort of like ping
back and forth
ideas for a talk and help you to to put
some more shape into it so so that's all
a possibility um again i mentioned
num focus and and uh their their
financial support for
open source projects already um they are
running
uh as a fund-raising effort an
end-of-year fundraising effort
um it's it's a program where basically
external supporters of non-focus
match donations that are coming in
between now
and the end of year up to a certain
amount so basically if you donate
uh ten dollars uh there is some some
other sponsor will match
that donation and put another ten
dollars in up to a certain maximum
amount of course
so uh that's a it's a really uh great
thing
to do and you know if you have some
spare cash you know consider doing it
there is also um a so-called telethon
event by james powell who is on
the board of num focus um
if some of you
have been to pi data events before like
conferences
um or meetups um james powell
is is a really regular speaker at pi
data events he
uh is kind of like a a
walking python reference book he knows
the language in and out and he's a very
very good speaker
so he is he's running this live coding
and and
enlightening talk present uh
presentation which
uh runs this saturday at 7 pm gmt
so my understanding is that he will do
some some live coding and he's going to
join by a couple of
uh big names from the open source and
python community
so and it's it's again it's like a
fundraising event so so you can join
that and it's and and and in the course
of this event
donate to nom focus but uh overall i
think it's going to be a really really
fun
event and i would encourage you guys to
take a look at it
okay um we
spoke already uh quite a bit about money
i'm going to speak a little bit more
about it
we the meet up are also indebted to our
sponsors
and i wanted to highlight them here so
these are all companies that are
well with the exception of num focus
these are all companies that are local
to cambridge in the uk and they are
supporting us
in various way for instance by paying
for our zoom licenses
for meet up fees um and fetch i have
paid for pizza many times when the
meetup was still happening in person
and raspberry pi the raspberry pi
foundation to be precise is our
venue sponsor um so
these are all uh great companies and not
only because they are supporting us
if you are interested in them and and
talk to them
in in any ways um then please do
mention that you heard about them at pi
data cambridge that
really does us a huge favor and it's
going to help us tremendously
in in you know recruiting more spawn
source
and uh and and getting uh any
sponsorship
contracts that are already exist renewed
so so you know please
do consider that um since i mentioned
jobs um so these are
updates from arm they are they are um as
i said they are headquartered here in
cambridge and the business
of uh of chip design in particular
um specialized on on uh energy saving
chips that are
frequently used in in mobile phones have
a look at these uh
job advertisements there's a lot of
interesting stuff going on
if you want more information um please
do
reach out to federico or leandro
who will be joining the the meter up
later on or go straight to the career
stage of um um
the raspberry pi foundation um for those
of you
who have not heard about them they are
the guys that are making these these
mini
and highly customizable computers so
that's the this raspberry pi computer
that is very popular
among students but also digital makers
and
and the raspberry pi foundation is
running a lot of educational program
around this raspberry pi platform so
here's the link
to their to their um educational
platform onto their programs if
this is something that interests you
please do check out
their their programs they are really
very active especially nowadays when
they are not
running any in-person events um
last but not least uh fetch ai is
also a local company local to cambridge
they are in the business of of machine
learning and decentralized
infrastructure
if if some of you have been to our
october meetup i believe there we had to
fetch ai uh scientists give give a talk
here
and explaining their ideas around
running machine learning
in a decentralized networks and using
uh um using digital ledgers to exchange
results and estimates between the
machine learning models
um so so there is some really cool stuff
going on around collective learning
if this sounds interesting you know
please do reach out to them there's an
email address and the discord channel
i do know that they're also hiring
regularly even if there are no
job advertisements advertised here on
this slide so you know do
check them out if you're looking for an
interesting job
so last but not least i promise to to
mention how to contact the um
meetup organizers as i said already we
are always looking for speakers
we also looking for sponsors so if you
have job openings that you want to
advertise
or anything else related to to data
and and open source software please get
in touch with us
um you can do that in various ways we
are on twitter
at pidatacambridge or you can also gmail
email us at pidatacambridge gmail.com
okay that is that was the
introduction thank you very much for
listening
um if there are no
um no questions on the chat and i don't
see any right now
then i'm going to hand over to isaac
who is going to speak to us about the
deep
time series models and their loss
functions
okay sure um let me see
i'll get started here um
i'll just throw up my screens oh
no it says host disabled attendee screen
sharing when i click share screen
okay um so yeah i think i can share now
um okay offer this
up um okay
so um everyone see my screen okay
yes it's looking great okay
[Music]
um
okay so um okay so yeah tonight i'm
going
or tonight or this afternoon
my time i'm gonna talk about kind of
finding the right loss functions um for
your deep time series forecasting models
or also
and also just a little bit about flow
forecast which is an open source deep
learning for time
series framework that i'm the creator
and maintainer of
actually it's good to mention i do like
presenting at pi data we were
in our repo was recently actually just
at pi data global an official open
source sprint there
so if anyone's interested in
contributing
um please let us know
and yeah so um okay so yeah
i guess onto the topic of a brief
introduction
so um so yeah one of my
major interests is kind of time series
forecasting
um and also time series classification
in particular using deep learning models
to apply it to real world problems
in the past at some of my work i've
forecasted
things like demand for retail items and
stores for better store stocking
agricultural yields and right now i'm
working on um kind of both
uh forecasting uh um
um both forecasting covid and also some
kind of other flash flood and stream and
river flow forecasting
uh so um yeah one of my major interests
is
is using deep learning models because i
think they offer a lot of benefits over
kind of the
manual type of feature engineering for
uh other models
um and i recently gave actually if
you're interested in hearing more about
kind of
deep learning for time series i gave a
talk at
twimlfest i don't know if people are
familiar but it's a podcast where uh
but anyways it was basically an hour
long and i went into detail about
why it's not used in industry a lot uh
deep learning models and uh
how it can be i don't have time to
obviously go over that all
here but uh that's kind of a lot more
detailed
view of some of what i'll be talking
about tonight
um so i've also given talks on
reproducibility breast practices
and kind of how that formed the basis of
our open source project
flow forecast if you're interested in
that
um so yeah on to the main subject for
tonight i
assume majority of people here are
familiar with
time series forecasting but if you
aren't and kind of the general kind of
metrics and loss functions if you use
if you don't hear kind of three of the
more common ones
um there are others too we have things
like mean squared error which is
basically
uh as the name implies just the you know
actual
minus predicted squared and then you
take an
average over all the different time
steps you have
mean absolute error which is just
basically the absolute value
also averaged over the time steps you
mean average percentage error
which is very similar to mae but just
expressed as a percentage which
some people and some business folks like
because they're familiar with
percentages more
um but uh but so these are coming
probably i'd say the three most common
ones i see a lot
and particularly when coming from i
guess research
um uh research you know you don't often
think a lot about what metric you choose
you know usually there's another paper
that's already like tested a deep
learning model
and they use one of these metrics so
you're just like oh i just have to show
my model performs better with this
metric than
this uh than this paper but when you're
doing stuff uh
particularly in industry or applying
deep learning models to real problems it
becomes really important
uh which metric you choose
for evaluation for a whole host of
reasons like explainability to
stakeholders maybe
maybe the data is like very messy and
one of these
doesn't work well which i'll talk about
in a second
and then sometimes even in research to
come out because some of these actually
used as a loss
as kind of the loss will will
cause weird things to happen when you're
training your model
which i'll talk about in a second um so
yeah using these i've run into various
problems so
um some more than others so uh yeah i'll
go on to kind
common problems um this is not my
diagram this was actually the diagram
from a paper at
nurex 2019 but i think it illustrates
stuff well
basically here's like common mean
squared error
and and basically i don't know if people
can see these but essentially
in each one of these uh graphs the mean
squared error is actually exactly the
same
it's like eight through all three of
these so
and obviously if you look at these this
this one probably is not a good forecast
when you actually plot it out
so this kind of reaffirms this point
that sometimes you could get
a very low like mean squared error but
then when you actually
plot you know your forecast versus
actual values
um this isn't great whereas of course
this one
is exactly the same mean squared error
but
uh um but but
it's it's obviously fitting the data
much more as this mentions here there's
just kind of a time delay
so basically one of the the what this
paper proposed and i've actually
we've implemented this in flow forecast
too that you can train models
on is called the dilate loss function
and basically it takes into
consideration both the shape and kind of
time delay so
here you can see that here the dilate
loss is
significantly worse than say
here or or here
um but the dilate loss is essentially
like in foreign part two
is essentially um two main components
which is
the uh the shape and the time
component um and and yeah i have used it
and as i'll
show from some actual examples in a
minute sometimes works well
um it sometimes works well and i
definitely like the idea of it
more than kind of msc because
particularly with some of my stream and
river flow forecast
uh you get a very good msc value
but then you go to applaud it and it's
like entirely
the forecast is essentially doing
something similar to this
um so anyways that's kind of an overview
of some of the
some of those common problems and uh at
least one last function
that can help with those um
another one thing i like to use a bit is
mean absolute scaled
error um it's some of the problems of
mae
but it also helps a lot with if you're
converting
if you're comparing things of different
uh
of different magnitudes i know r
squared is used a bit for this too but
um
i think mesa is better both kind of as a
as an
actual loss function and an aerometric
it's actually what one of my colleagues
at
monster recommended to me a while ago
um back when i was working there um but
anyways basically the idea is you just
have the
mean absolute error and then you divide
it by
of the model so this would be like the
mean absolute area of the model and you
divide it by
kind of a naive baseline
and this is nice because then
essentially it's
it's scaled so like if you had say like
two products
just as an instance at a store and one
one
sold a lot um and you wanted to test
and the other didn't sell a lot at all
so like one say you had
like a thousand sales a day and the
other you had like say
uh 10 sales a day and you wanted to find
a model that was good at
forecasting both the sales for both of
them
um you know and could perform well
equally then you could essentially even
take
using mace you could take the
performance on
product one and directly comp and pro in
the performance forecasting product two
and say like average them together
because
this is essentially giving you a scale
over
kind of the baseline and it's also
interesting because you could
essentially use anything as your
baseline
as i'll say in a second so you could
even use a fairly ever
a fairly good other model and then that
really will force the
loss to be like really compared to like
another method
rather than just kind of uh
um the the actual uh
well it still uses the actual values but
it will like
definitely scale it in proportion so you
won't like wind up with
really huge losses if it's a very hard
problem
um so um so yeah and i've also found
it's good for seasonal
stuff as well so um with that said uh
now i'm going to talk a bit about our
open source framework so flow forecast
is basically a deporting for time
series forecasting framework uh
developed by myself
and several others written in pie torch
um uh we have a bunch of kind of them
very modern like deep learning for time
series models
we actually make it our mission like as
soon as like a good model comes out of a
conference or something to very quickly
implement it and port it to our
framework um
on more the reproducibility side we make
it very easy to use configuration files
to track
experiments and hyperparameters we're
integrated with weights and biases so we
have
so we have easy hyperparameter searches
we also have cloud integration so
in particular we're very integrated with
gcp so you can reference data directly
in buckets
and spin up instances using flow
forecast very easy for that and
automatically save your weights config
files and stuff to gcp
we're working more on aws integration
but i guess related to our topic using
these configuration files we
also make it really easy to like swap
in and out different loss functions to
see how your
models uh perform so um
so yeah it's kind of our framework and
i'll run and actually so
now i'll leave slideshow and show a
couple
different examples of some of this stuff
so
um yeah as i said uh we basically log
everything to weights and biases
so this was a model i think this was
one of actually of our covid forecasting
models
essentially trained uh trained using
standard mean squared error
you can see loss pretty much goes down
and then
validation loss is a little more uh
wonky but that's in part because we had
a very small validation set because we
don't have a long temporal history for
kovid um we do use early stopping so we
actually re
our framework imac restores the weights
back to the lowest point with validation
loss
but anyways one of the things i was
going to show
is like the difference between training
a model with the different kind of
things now actually all these models
performed fairly well not because these
were actually pre-trained using
extensive transfer learning and then
using metadata from locations
so none of these perform that badly but
this is an example of like one of the
models trains
with mean squared error
and here you can see uh while we use
confidence intervals
as well um full forecast makes it very
easy to use confidence intervals
uh but i guess then like one of those
things you see is like
um is is is like
this kind of gets some of the shape but
it's kind of hard to tell because the
confidence interval expands here
however actually like this kind of looks
like
at this point with the covet forecast
there's kind of a downward trend
um so by the way it's this it's this
orange line that's the actual
actual values um and then it's the blue
line that's
our predicted one or well one of the
predictive ones and then the confidence
interval
the confidence interval is constructed
using drop out essentially so
we just run the prediction a bunch of
times with dropout
that's kind of the ci for it um so
that's just kind of a example and then
as i said we use uh
but probably more importantly we use
these kind of different
as i say configuration files and the
nice thing about this with weights and
biases
is that our full configuration file is
essentially locked here
so what happens is essentially um
oh yeah this was actually root mean
squared or ever but that that's just
essentially the square root
um so this was like the forecast on um
and it looks like a county uh in texas
where we were forecasting and this was
kind of the root mean squared error this
is the model name
um and i'll show you where you would
actually enter these parameters and
stuff but
that's kind of the overall view
of that so um so yeah
and then we can look at another one uh
where
for instance we use mace uh you'll
immediately see like that the
loss the way the loss looks is
a bit different um though this is pretty
similar since
there isn't a huge difference um i
think if we go down by the way all these
other charts i'm scrolling through are
basically our interpretability
plots so we automatically log a bunch of
interpretability charts so people can
see
stuff um so but we can see that
this is this looks a bit better training
with mace
here um confidence interval does seem to
more
envelop this whole area and kind of the
stuff does trend a bit
further downward uh at least it looks
that way
it would of course be good to plot these
all out more
but it does look like just based off
this graph
that mace uh encourages a bit better
predictions
in this area um so um
so yeah and then i don't think there's
too much of difference between mason the
dilate loss but
um whatever you can like certainly see
that
um yeah loss loss with dilate
sometimes is a little harder to converge
that's why i've seen because
dilate loss because it takes those
components into consideration
it is very is larger but i think
in the end you do see validation loss to
you like
does do a more steady downward stream
overall
um these were kind of hard models too
and you don't see really smooth curves
because the
the data set for covid's obviously very
limited it's a very
new disease uh so um
oh i guess the one for dilate loss
actually didn't work as well um
but so that's interesting but i guess
the one the big points here is the two
that just
is that depending on the loss function
you might want to experiment with a
bunch of different loss functions and
then kind of track
track how they work um and then but
and that's why we make it really easy
and kind of flow forecast
um to do that so um
so yeah yeah so here you see here's the
configuration and there's dilate loss
um so i wonder how i'm doing on time but
anyways i'll just quickly show what kind
of our actual one of our training
notebooks looks like
this is actually for training one of our
river flow forecasting things
uh you still have you still have five to
ten minutes if you want to use it
sorry just because you asked okay yeah
yeah i just wasn't keeping track so yeah
that sounds good
um so basically uh so basically here
um uh here as i said we define all of
our models by configuration files
because this works really well for
reproducibility purposes
and as you see these are logged to
weights and biases
as well so this is the example of kind
of
creating a configuration file but
literally in most cases as i said
like changing the loss function is as
easy as just
changing this in the configuration file
so this is currently using me root mean
squared error
if i want to use say like
the dilate loss i just change this to
dilate loss
here and then this would train using the
dilate loss
which is nice if i some some
things like mace for instance if you
wanted to use
mace as your loss function they do
require like a a
second set of parameters for what the
baseline method is
so you can see i just had this comment
out here but then i
i can actually specify what the baseline
method is so here
it's mean um you remember with mace
because it's like
the mean absolute error over uh
of the base a baseline mean absolute
error so here it's mean so this just
means whatever the mean
is and that uh forecast history that's
passed into the model
it will use as kind of the baseline
method for
that um we are working on having others
so you could potentially even use
another model here
and then that would be kind of the
quote-unquote baseline method
but so yeah that's kind of how it's very
easy to just switch back and forth
between the loss functions
uh when uh using kind of our setup i'll
just change that back to rmse
the second thing you can do is you can
actually log multiple metrics too when
evaluating
um so i s i'm not sure if i did
any of the ones here but for instance
like if when evaluating
you can have like evaluate and add both
like
mace and the dilate loss or something
i'll see quickly
um if i did that here um
yeah i don't know if i don't think i did
it in this one per se but
if you had multiple ones here they'd
appear right one right after the other
in terms of evaluation so you could
then see it um
i might have one where is it back here
oh yeah so here here's one where i had
it one run where i had it so say here's
dilate loss um and here's rmse so you
can kind of see what both
look like and then uh if you run a
parameter sweep so this is actually a
parameter sweep where we're
sweeping over different values for batch
size
learning rate forecast history forecast
length
number of encoder layers since it's
using a it's basically stacking
various self-attention blocks and
dropout rates um so then you could
wait where'd that one go um so then like
as i was saying you could um
i got confused by my windows um
oh yeah yeah here but here's like an
overview of sweep like you'd have say 36
runs
but then all i was saying here is then
you could pick the metric you want to
sort the runs by
so you could for instance here sort the
runs by
dilate loss to see the best with the
dilate loss
or if you could if you wanted to you
could sort the runs by the
uh by rmse as well and see the best
according to rmse and just you know
explore which ones are those
um so uh that's one of i think the good
things about being integrated with
weights and biases which is actually
also another open source and free to use
framework
um so yeah that's that's kind of the
overview of our stuff
we really like using these configuration
files
because in a similar vein too this
doesn't apply just
to say uh doesn't it apply just to say
like
the the loss function either you can
swap a bunch
of stuff in and out you can swap the
optimizer as well so you could use atom
or sgd
you could even swap the model though
then so if i want to use a different
model i change the model name to
whatever model
it is or then and then swap out these
parameters
etc etc to match whatever model
parameters um though then i would have
to modify the
sweep because there are some ones like
the encoder layers
dependent on that so that's kind of the
example of that
um uh and uh
and yeah as i as i think i mentioned
before too we do have these
interpretability heat maps so i think
so yeah this was another one of our
kovid ones
um there are a bunch of different ones
but for instance
here i don't know if this was a very
good model but looks like it was mainly
paying attention to the previous cases
and the mobility of parks when making
its predictions
um in reality it would probably have
been using more of these other features
but
it seems like it weighed these two very
heavily um
so uh though
though yeah so i mean the predictions
aren't the best but
worked okay so um yeah again our our
repository is
is just called flow forecast we're on
we're on github
um we're we're licensed under
gpl free so we're definitely committed
to being an open
source so if anyone's interested in
using it
we do have extensive documentation or if
you want to contribute we're
always looking for contributors um so
yeah i think that sums up my
talk does anyone have any questions
a q a i guess yeah thanks a lot for
for the talk by the way um i i think
there was
someone who was asking about the url for
the
podcast that you mentioned at the
beginning um
is that the right one that was posted
here on the chat
uh the url for which uh
the podcast that you mentioned the
oh yeah the overall the overall um
the the one where the long talk i gave
on deep learning for time
series yeah so there
i can post it here if anyone's
uh if anyone sees
it um wait where's chat oh chat's there
in the zoom client um okay yeah here it
is
yeah okay yeah that yeah it's on youtube
so anyone can see it oh i think i see an
answer here
or a question do you use input only
discharge data
um yeah so for the river flow for
forecasting
um basically uh
what we use is precipitation temperature
and river flow data right now we're also
working on integrating gauge
metadata so like what elevation it is
what latitude
and longitude uh those are the primary
free
um actually this is a good opportunity i
guess this show
so like say if you with with our
framework we have
a different like uh you can you can take
whatever columns you want
from a csv so basically in your data
loader params
the columns you want to use you
basically specify so
here we specify relevant columns are the
cubic feet per second
the precipitation and the temperature
and then the target column is the cubic
feet per second
so that's kind of how our dataset params
work um
and if we were going to use other things
there we would just add it as kind of
i don't know we don't actually have soil
moisture now but
if we say had a column with soil
moisture we just
add the column name and then it would be
used here
so
cool thank you very much that looks
really like
a lot of work oh yeah okay i see another
question here
by paul also in the q a
do you still have time to answer that
yeah yeah sure um so yeah i think with
mace uh uh mace i think the advantage is
that like it's kind of
uh in particular it's it's it's
basically
scaling to whatever the baseline method
is
even if it is a even if it is a
complex model um so
so for instance like in some of these
river flow cases it's very hard to
forecast um stuff particularly when
rivers that are dam controlled and they
might release dams at arbitrary
dates even i know like even on those
seasonal patterns
so if you have so the problem is
particularly with standard loss
functions
your loss could easily kind of explode
so to speak by getting some of those
predictions wrong so one of the nice
things about
mace in using like another model with it
is then it will at least be scaled with
respect to
uh with kind of respect to that
um so so there is some benefit uh
i think if you look at like uh robert
heinemann i think's the one originally
um proposed it he uh he has a good more
further reference on that so
okay thank you very much i see there's
another question from
krish who has uh send it only to to the
panelist um
so uh chris asks is it possible to
reproduce the
same result as shown using the documents
and github
please um
um yeah i mean we we have we have this
we have the reproducibility uh stuff so
we log the config so you should be able
to reproduce it using the same config
and then the notebook i don't know if
we've put all of our notebooks on
github we've we've used a lot of them
but the core
the core framework and there are
examples of notebooks there
um but yeah if you want to reproduce it
it should be reproducible
using the same config and then
since that's that's what matters there
there is sometimes randomness basically
in random seeds
with both numpy and pi torch uh we're
trying to reduce that now but
for the most part you should get pretty
much the same result if you use
the same config and the same
configuration file
um and and you know same the same setup
so okay
very good yeah i i was really
impressed by the framework and the
the level of of diagnostics plot that
you
you you produce there that was quite
quite neat to see
um let's see i don't see any other
questions
on the chat um
and the q a maybe uh taking a step back
just one very last question we have
a lot of people that is are very
interested in like a machine learning
and data science career
can you maybe tell those people that are
at the beginning of their career a
little bit how you got
started and then sort of like you know
what
steps you took to to get involved in
deep learning
um yeah sure so um
so yeah for me i guess it really was i
did take some coursework in college
um but i i didn't do anything that heavy
or anything
so for what i i really learned a lot
particularly doing like competitions on
kaggle and then
after that i really learned a lot just
by trying to find
interesting projects uh like and then
making them open source
so for instance some of my stream and
flash flood research just started by uh
i paddled white water a lot so i wanted
to know like when the stream would be
flowing so i was like wait that could be
a good machine learning project
and so so i really learned a lot just by
kind of finding interesting projects
and working on them and i think open
source
contributions are an often underrated
thing because if you have like a lot of
good open source contributions
then you have like basically a footprint
like on
that any hiring manager or anyone can
see so
at least for me if someone has like a
lot of good open source
projects that i can look over and see
their code and how they interact
i might not even give them like an
arduous coding test because i've already
seen kind of
some of their stuff so so i always find
that useful
would be my advice i guess so
yes yes i can i can only echo that sort
of like having
visible code out there on github or
anywhere else where it's visible is
really very useful
um and a good sign for for good coders
um yeah that sounds great
um i i think i i cut your your
introduction a little bit short at the
beginning um
sorry about that i i think i read
somewhere that you're also
um involved in a pi data
chapter in in maine in in the us
i think it was in in ono did i remember
that correctly do you want to give a
quick shout out to your uh to to our
uh sister or or brother uh pi data
meetup and and are there any events
coming up that you want to highlight
um yeah sure so i mean for a while i was
the organizer
uh i still i still organize a bit for pi
data or now which is kind of
a small community in maine um we're
definitely a smaller chapter of pi
data but we uh since we're kind of in a
rural area maine but at the same time
we've had a lot of interesting talks on
uh you know uh
machine learning and forestry and other
area
and other kind of industries that affect
our area agriculture as well
so yeah feel free to check us out on the
pi data
page as well um we haven't been too
active recently just because it's
been hard i think like yourself it's
been hard for us to get speakers
and uh but but so uh yeah feel free to
check us out
or volunteer to be a speaker if you're
interested
in presenting to a us crowd i guess so
great okay thank you very much isaac
that's uh yeah
thanks a lot for uh the talk
um i have not been able to locate the
second speaker so it's
very well possible that this is the end
of the meetup so
one last uh shout out to
to then roython then if you're
uh on the among the attendees if you
dialed in and i didn't see it
just a post to the chat
and and and you you would be ready to go
but yeah i think that means no
okay so so dan has emailed me uh
about an hour ago and and said he had
some um some
scheduling difficulties tonight um so he
could probably not make it and i guess
this means that he's really
not been able to join so yeah very sorry
um
to anyone who was uh looking forward um
to his talk about gaussian processes i
think that that was his
theme so we're just trying to you know
get him in at some point in 2021 and
um i guess that's it for 2020 um
i yeah i hope you you guys had fun
and if if you know if there's anything
that you want to
tell us about any feedback or proposals
for talk you know we are always very
happy to chat
to read out you know on on email or
twitter i'm going to post the the
introductory slide deck
or the link to the introductory slide
deck on the meetup page so
you can you can find our contact details
there
and that's it thank you much for dialing
in
and enjoy the rest of 2020 and have a
good start into the
next year i hope i'll see you at one of
our
meetups next year bye
you